there are a lot of fake quotes
attributed to the great stoic
philosopher Epictetus floating around
out there and as opposed to some of the
other videos that I've done in this
series
unmasking identifying fake quotes where
most of them are definitely
not by the person that they're
attributed to and we're able to say
exactly where they came from some of the
fake quotes are not quite as fake when
it comes to Epictetus in part because
they come from people who are trying to
do something nice for their readers and
I suppose for Epictetus and that is to
put Epictetus into their own words that
is to paraphrase or engage in what we
call a gloss unfortunately
when this happens
a lot of the meaning gets changed or
left out or something new is added in
and then people who don't know any
better or perhaps are
what should we say a little bit
lackadaisical in checking their sources
immediately assume that if it's in a
book that's attributed to Epictetus it
must be by Epictetus and they go ahead
and repeat it as if it's a genuine quote
so as we're going to see quite a few of
them are going to stem from one book in
particular that has done that in recent
years so let's go on to the fake quotes
we begin with one and you notice here
that the person who has quoted it is
actually using the wrong image but in a
certain sense it's not quite the wrong
image he has just attributed it to the
wrong person the greater the difficulty
the more glory in surmounting it
skillful Pilots gain their reputation
from storms and Tempest and you notice
that that's not Epic titus's image it
right there but rather epicurus an easy
mistake to make if one is not doing due
diligence on the internet and as it
turns out this comes from a book about
epicurus by Charles
Ramon an essay on the Vindication of
epicurus and his Doctrine so not
something by Epictetus at all
we have another funny epicurus related
one where people again are mixing them
up either God wants to abolish evil and
cannot or he can but does not want to
this would be an extraordinary thing for
Epictetus to be saying probably one of
the most religious of the stoics whose
works we currently have and this is from
the famous formulation of the problem of
evil a way of denying Providence and we
get this through lactancius who is
summarizing
epicurus's arguments so again clearly
not a genuine quote by Epictetus but
expressing something that he would never
get behind
now we get to uh more plausible one with
this quote circumstances don't make the
man they only reveal him to himself and
we actually know where this does come
from you can find this quote out there
attributed properly to this guy James
Allen as man thinketh is the book so
it's not Epictetus we're not quite sure
how this ended up getting attributed to
him other than the fact that Epictetus
does think that we do reveal our
character through our actions and you
know it is true that circumstances don't
make the person according to Epictetus
the person decides what kind of person
they're going to be but he didn't say
this
now here is another really interesting
one
Nature has given men one tongue but two
ears that we may hear from others twice
as much as we speak and there's a lot of
variations out there sometimes Nature
has given people one mouth but two ears
you see sometimes it's placed in this
older English form and it's being
attributed to Epictetus and I do have to
give credit to centenia antiqua here
they've got a whole discussion of this
proverb and as it turns out this is
coming from George Long's translations
of epictetus's fragments ostensibly
coming from stobeis but as the
Centennial antiqua people found out when
they went to look at it this is not
actually
from the Epictetus section but it's
borrowed erroneously from a section
where stobius is discussing Zeno who is
attributed to have said this particular
quote we don't know if either of them
actually said it but it made its way
into ancient discourse and then here we
see it being wrongly attributed to
Epictetus
finally we have one and we're not sure
where this one actually comes from he
who laughs at himself never runs out of
things to laugh at often quoted as being
my Epictetus it's not there in any of
epictetus's works not even in the
fragments
so nobody really knows where this one
comes from but you can find many books
and many websites attributing it to
Epictetus quite wrongly
now we get into the other half of our
quotations and you're going to notice a
common aspect to all of these so let's
take a look at this one the key is to
keep company only with people who uplift
you whose presence calls forth your best
now this is not by Epictetus it is
actually from Sharon LaBelle's very
popular The Art of Living and it's a
gloss on N Caribbean chapter 33. the
majority of her book is glosses on
Epictetus paraphrasing things often
adding new things in changing the
meaning slightly or sometimes changing
the meanings considerably so this is not
really genuine Epictetus this is
Epictetus filtered through Sharon
LaBelle it would be as if we were
quoting some other person who said as
Epictetus the gist of what he's saying
is this but there's nothing actually
like it in the text it would be weird to
see Epictetus talking about people
uplifting you or their presence calling
forth your best I'm not sure what that
would even Translate
let's look at the next one
caretake this moment immerse yourself in
its particulars respond to this person
this challenge this deed quit evasion
stop giving yourself needless trouble it
is time to really live to fully inhabit
the situation you happen to be in now
now if you've read a lot of Epictetus
you know he doesn't actually talk in
this sort of jargon this sounds rather
let's say new agey and this is also from
Sharon LaBelle's The Art of Living
directly from there verbatim word for
word so it's kind of like stuff that
Epictetus says at certain points but he
wouldn't say respond to this person this
challenge this deed he might say stop
giving yourself needless trouble but he
wouldn't say fully inhabit the situation
you happen to be in so again not a real
quote by Epictetus
we come to another one
from this instant on vow to stop
disappointing yourself separate yourself
from the mob decide to be extraordinary
and do what you need to do now
so this too is from Sharon LaBelle's The
Art of Living this is a gloss on
ncaridian chapter 51. it also Bears some
interesting
similarities to a quote attributed to
Edmund Hillary which doesn't appear to
be by him either famous mountain climber
it's actually from a Rolex ad where it
says people do not decide to become
extraordinary they decide to accomplish
extraordinary things there's a common
theme there isn't there of doing
extraordinary things and that's what
makes you
extraordinary so again not not Epictetus
himself here's another one do not try to
seem wise to others if you want to live
a wise life live it on your own terms
and in your own eyes this is straight
out of sharing the bells the art of
living and it might be in part A gloss
on Epictetus saying don't try to appear
to be a philosopher to others you know
keep that Under Wraps but he doesn't say
if you want to live a wise life living
on your own terms and in your own eyes
finally we get to something that some
people might say well no this isn't a
fake quote and I would actually give
them that because this is rather a
mistranslation that unfortunately takes
on a life of its own and winds up
becoming the internet meme that
essentially like you know gresham's law
bad money drives out good a bad
translation drives out the good ones
that you could find out there
small-minded people blame others average
people blame themselves the wise see all
blame as foolishness now if you know
your Epictetus and caridian you
recognize that as a kind of similar to
what's going on in chapter five but
here's how it actually
runs uh and well I should mention this
before we get into that LaBelle says
something a little bit more so so people
have kind of can Consolidated or
condensed what she says small-minded
people habitually reproach others for
their own misfortunes average people
reproach themselves those who are
dedicated to a life of wisdom understand
that the impulse to blame something or
someone is foolishness now what did
Epictetus actually say
well here's a closer translation it is
the part of an uneducated person the
word there that is referring to
education paideia right an undeveloped
person so it's not a small-minded person
per se it is the part of the uneducated
person to blame others where he himself
fares ill to blame himself is the part
of one whose education has begun the
person who has started becoming formed
and then to blame neither another nor
his own self is the part of one whose
education is complete notice nothing
there about the impulse to blame
something or someone is foolishness this
is something that got added in
through that book The Art of Living and
so is it a fake quote isn't it a fake
quote well I'll leave that for you to
decide yourself I just think that nobody
should be reposting repeating uh and
relying upon those as unfortunately so
many people are doing
as always I'll close here by saying
whenever you see something that seems a
little off you should exercise some
healthy suspicion you should try to see
if you can figure out where this came
from if it doesn't have a citation with
the work that it's supposed to have come
from you should actually be a bit iffy
about it you want to demand the sources
and if you're not sure whether something
is a fake quote don't repost it right
don't regurgitate it don't rely upon it
if you do well then somebody may come
along to point out that you have built
your house of cards on a foundation of
sand if we want to mix a couple
metaphors here so there's all of that to
think about and I do really suggest
checking out the website sentencia
antique why they are sleuths in finding
and identifying and then and telling us
about the background of fake quotes from
ancient philosophy so that is it for
this one we've got plenty more fake
quotes with other authors other thinkers
other great philosophers coming up down
the line